producers
scientists community leaders athletes or
frontline workers
ukrainian canadians continue to make a
tremendous contribution to our country
but the friendship between canada and
ukraine is not only based on this shared
history
it is also based on our shared values
vladimir in the years i've known you
i've always thought of you as a champion
for democracy and now
democracies around the world are lucky
to have you as our champion
[Applause]
your courage and the courage of your
people
inspires us all
you're defending the right of ukrainians
to choose their own future
and in doing so
you're defending the values that form
the pillars of all
free democratic countries
freedom
human rights
justice
truth
international order
these are the values
you're risking your life for
as you fight for ukraine
and ukrainians
beyond that
you're inspiring democracies and
democratic leaders around the world
to be more courageous more united and to
fight harder for what we believe in
you remind us
that friends are always stronger
together
with allies and partners we're imposing
crippling sanctions to make sure putin
and his enablers in russia and belarus
are held accountable
today in line with our european union
partners i can announce that we have
imposed severe sanctions on 15 new
russian officials including government
and military elites who are complicit in
this illegal war
canada
canada will continue to support ukraine
with military equipment as well as
financial and humanitarian assistance
and we will be there to help rebuild
once the aggressor is repelled
in canada
we like to root for the underdog
we believe that when a cause is just and
right it will always prevail no matter
the size of the opponent
this doesn't mean it'll be easy
ukrainians are already paying
incalculable human costs
this
illegal
and unnecessary war is a grave mistake
and putin must stop it now
[Applause]
[Music]
vladimir putin's blatant disregard for
human life is absolutely unacceptable
canada continues to demand that russia
stop targeting civilians and end this
unjustifiable war
ukrainians
are standing up to authoritarianism
and as parliamentarians united in this
house today and
all canadians
we stand with you
as friends you can count on our
unwavering
and steadfast support
and now
it is my great privilege to introduce to
you all
the president of ukraine
our friend
volodymir zalinski
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
mr speaker prime minister
dear justin
members of the government
members of the parliament
all distinguished guests
friends
before i begin i would like you to
understand
my feelings
and feelings of all ukrainians
as far as it is possible
our feelings over the last 20 days
20 days
[Music]
imagine that one on 4am each of you
you start hearing me
explosions
severe explosion justin can you imagine
hearing
your children
hear all these severe explosions
of airport bombing
other cities
you're a wonderful country can you
imagine that
missiles
have been bombed and destroyed by
russian federation
and you know how many people already
died
can you only imagine what words how can
you explain to your children
[Music]
you know that this is the word to
subjugate your people
and on second day
you receive
notifications that huge
cons of military equipment are entering
your country crossing the border they
entering small
cities
they are
giving siege this
encircling cities
and
and they start to shell civil
neighborhoods
they bombed school buildings they
destroyed kindergarten facilities
like in our city city of sume like in
the city of akhtarkam
imagine that someone is taking siege
lane siege to vancouver can you just
imagine them for a second
and all these people who are left in
such city and this is exactly the
situation that our city of marijuana is
suffering right now
and they are left without heat or hydro
or without means of communicating
almost without food
without water
seeking shelter in bomb shelters
dear justin
yes can you imagine
that every day you receive
memorandums about the number of
casualties including among women and
children
you've heard
about the bombings
currently we have 97 children that died
during this war
can you imagine famous cn tower in
toronto
if they if it was hit by
russian bombs
of course i don't
wish this on anyone but this is our
reality in which we live we have to
contemplate we have to see where the
next bombing will take
place
uh your churches well we have a freedom
square in the city of
of
in the city of garten our bobbin here
the place where
victims of holocaust were buried and
they they it has been bombed by the
russians
imagine that canadian
facilities have been bombed
similarly as our
buildings
and memorial places are being bombed
a number of families
have died
every night is a horrible night
russians are shelling
from all kinds of artillery from tanks
they're hitting civilian infrastructure
they're hitting
being buildings
can you imagine that there is a
fire starting at a nuclear power plant
and that's exactly what happened in our
country
each city that they are
marching through they're taking down
ukrainian flags can you imagine someone
taking down your canadian flags in
montreal and other canadian cities i
know that you all support ukraine
ukraine
we've been friends with you justin but
also i would like you to understand
and i would like you to feel this
what we feel every day
we want to live
and we want to be victorious we want to
prevail for the sake of life
can you imagine when you
when you call your friends your friendly
nation and you ask
please close the sky
close the airspace please stop the
bombing how many more cruise missiles
have to fall on our cities
until you
make this happen
and they in return they express their
deep concerns about the situation
when we talk to with our
partners and they say please hold on
hold on
a little longer
some people are talking about
trying to avoid the escalation
and at the same time
in response to our aspiration to become
members of nature we also do not hear a
clear answer
sometimes we don't see
obvious things it's a difficult but it
also allowed us to see who our real
friends are over the last 20 days and as
well eight previous years
i am sure that you've been able to see
clearly what's going on
and i'm dressing all of you
canada has always
been steadfast
in their support if you've been a
reliable
partner to ukraine and ukrainians and
i'm sure this will continue
you've offered your help your assistant
at our earliest request you supply us
with the military census with
humanitarian assistance
you impose severe sanctions serious
sanctions at the same time we see that
unfortunately this
they did not bring the end to the war
you can see that our cities like kharkiv
and many other cities are not protected
just like your cities are protected
edmonton vancouver you can see that cave
is being shelled and bombed ivano friend
city of anna from kids
it used to be a very peaceful country
peaceful cities but now they're being
constantly bombarded bombarded basically
what i am trying to say that we all need
to do you all need to do more to stop
russia to protect ukraine and by doing
that to protect europe from russian
threat they destroying everything
memorial complexes
schools
hospitals
housing complex
they already killed 97 ukrainian
children
we're not asking for much we're asking
for justice for real support which will
help us to prevail to defend
to save life to save life all over the
world canada is leading in these efforts
and i'm hoping that other countries will
follow the same
suit we're asking for more of your
leadership
and please take more
uh greater part
in these efforts justin and all of our
friends of our of ukraine
old friends of the truth
please understand how important it is
for us to close our airspace
from russian missiles and russian
aircrafts i hope you can understand
i hope you can
increase your efforts you can increase
sanctions so they don't so they will not
have a single dollar to fund their war
effort
commercial entities should not be
working in russia
probably you know better than many in
any other countries that this attack on
ukraine it's in their attempt to
annihilate ukrainian people and there is
nothing else to it this is their main
objective
it's actually the war against ukrainian
people
it's an attempt to
destroy everything that we as ukrainians
do it's an attempt to destroy our future
to destroy our nation our character
you canadians do know very well
all this that's why i'm asking you
please do not stop in your efforts
please expand your efforts
to bring back peace
in our peaceful country
i believe and i know that you can do it
and
we are building we are part of the
anti-war coalition and jointly i'm sure
that will achieve results i would like
to also ask our ukrainian diaspora in
canada
this is a historical moment
and we need your support your practical
support
and we hope that with your practical
steps you will
show that you are part of the
modern ukrainian history
remember this is a
practical
modern day
history of ukraine we want to live
we want to have peace
i am grateful
to everyone of you in the parliament of
canada who is present there to every
canadian citizens
i am very grateful to you justin
i am grateful to
canadian people and i am confident that
together we will overcome and will be
victorious
glory to ukraine
thank you to canada
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
you